roll-on is back in style resplendent
adam here's where i ask you that
question what's that should we do the
show
today i think we should i think we
should too
let's do it
born
in 1966.
he turned his life around
he wasn't doing so hot
[Music]
he got rid of that weight
and he gained a lot of wisdom
he lives in a tent
[Applause]
thank you all so much
for playing along
and i hope you have a wonderful night
and i'd like to welcome to the stage
mr
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to roll on where
my journalist appendage mr adam skolnick
and i rip matters of interest from the
headlines and our lived experience we
riff on sports culture entertainment
self-betterment we answer a few listener
questions and so much more today we've
got a fun
i should say light in comparison to at
least
uh the roll-on from two weeks ago
uh show today we're gonna announce the
winners of the 2021 rollies very
exciting talk a little bit of endurance
news answer one single listener question
and once again we're gonna close with a
coaching call check in with friend of
the pod my coach chris houth
the man guiding me towards
this perhaps ill-fated 12 and a half
mile open water swim race that is uh
looming on my calendar but first
how goes a comrade
rich
larry ellison owes me 25
that sounds like a story
it's not that great of a story but i
went you know with a family and i we
went to the tennis tournament larry's
tennis tournament indian wells
and
uh we had two days planned one day we
went we took my parents we got like two
stadium seats and we had two grounds
passes and we brought zuma because april
was a very high-ranked junior tennis
player in australia so tennis is a big
deal in our house
and um
so anyway we we we parked the car we
have we we parked the car in this
huge grassy lot looks like the coat size
of coachella festival and as we're
walking we're pushing the stroller it's
a vaccinated only entrance thing
and zuma's under five can't be vaxxed
but usually they're you know they're
allowed in anyway
but in this case we had all the people
who were working in the parking lot
saying they're not gonna let them in
they're not gonna let them in so we were
prepared
i go up to the to the counter or
whatever the ticket place to get my
refund because i said well okay i'll
just get my money back
couldn't go because they wouldn't let
zoom in
and uh nowhere on the website doesn't
say you know you have under five aren't
aren't allowed
uh and so then but she wouldn't give me
my
my
parking
refund because she couldn't because it's
been scanned yeah so like there was no
way for her to do it and so i'm like
okay and so she said you can just call
you know email this guy
and he'll he'll uh larry ellison and
director turned out to be larry
and um yeah i haven't heard back yet
okay yeah
so how are we going to
get justice for you for this
you know larry's very busy i don't want
to be an apologist for larry he is very
busy he does owe me 25 and i am gonna
tack some interest on there well maybe
when you're out swimming you'll see him
fly by on one of his sailboats yeah well
to make matters worse i i shorted
twitter
yeah not smart yeah because um but who
knows elon comes in he's a regular at
the b and j
and uh he's not a jerry yeah yeah he
comes and he gets you that won't die he
gets a triple scoop i mean i'm just
saying and and he he told me he was
going to buy twitter he was going to
bullrush twitter and i didn't i thought
he was kidding because he's that kind of
guy we have a like that's your rapport
like you and i right you know we have a
thing
and uh and i thought he was [ __ ] with
me so i shorted twitter
it's going gonna be interesting to see
what pans out with that i know it's all
upside down poison pill and everything
that's a different podcast though we're
not gonna we're not gonna pick that one
apart today we're not getting into
elon's head today um i will say that i
stood behind larry ellison in line at
cvs once
how did that go i don't know i mean it
was just he was buying band-aids or
something i can't even remember this was
years ago celebrities what's interesting
is that you know he owns like an insane
amount of malibu beachfront property
including i think where like nobu and
the soho house is and doesn't he on the
mountain region and the rio i think so
yeah yeah and lanai he owns the islands
like that whole island right yeah um
founder of oracle for people that don't
know which is and he made a uh he did
make he did make an appearance in uh
in founder television did you watch the
dropout
i watched the first because we were
talking i watched the first episode of
this yeah yeah yeah so he he he is
portrayed in that miniseries
including a scene with elizabeth holmes
played by amanda seyfried on it on one
of his yachts
in the san francisco it does seem to
live well yeah
anyway uh that is all a side of what
we're actually going to talk about today
um yes but first i should probably check
in with what's going on yeah what's
going on
you know i always ask you what's going
on with you you never ask me what's
going on with me
i feel like i feel like i'm missing
unfulfilled i'm in this relationship
every week i miss my you know
it has to be two it has to be two ways
that's what i told elon yesterday okay
anyway um i'm good
i uh was in miami like two weeks ago
and had this incredible experience i
hosted my first conference it was for
this organization called ypo young
president's organization i've done a lot
of events for this organization over the
years and what does that mean it's it's
basically like this global
organization
of young ceos and each kind of local
chapter functions almost like a
like a mastermind group where it's
pretty cool though like they really help
each other out and they have all these
like family community oriented
events and all this infrastructure but
it's essentially like
young ceos i think there's a cap on the
age limit okay and and it's you know
kind of like a way for them to
you know have a means to you know share
what's going on with them and have other
people help out et cetera info share and
they do like a lot of speaking stuff so
like when i went to pakistan and saudi
arabia and bahrain and morocco like all
of those were ypo events okay which is
cool but i do they cap on the boomers
when they're in private yeah
i don't know um but this was my first
uh stab at actually hosting like an
all-day event interesting had to be on
stage like i don't know 14 times over
the course of the day and it was a
wellness oriented thing where a lot of
friends of the podcast were actually the
speakers like matthew walker and walter
longo
laird and gabby were there dan buettner
um mark hyman was there ken cook from
the environmental working group
chip conley who's this hotelier who was
instrumental in helping build airbnb who
now has this thing called the modern
elder academy he was super cool cool um
ken and chip i'm definitely uh getting
on the podcast we're trying to schedule
all that right now but but my point
being like
i thought it would be like oh it'll be
cool like you just get up and you
introduce each guest like how hard can
it be right and then when i got into
like the responsibility of what that
entailed because you're you're basically
like charged with holding the energy of
the crowd and keeping this thing moving
right and having you know making sure
that everyone's really engaged and
interested in what's happening and um
ended up like rehearsing for like eight
hours the day before i wrote like a 35
page script and
then during the day was like revising
the script and trying to find jokes and
you know it was a cool challenge and
definitely like a puzzle that i've never
tried to assemble before but it was
pretty thrilling it went well yeah i dug
it it was super fun and everyone was
into it yeah i think so i mean i think
it went really well and i found like a
groove with it i found it to be more
fulfilling than just being one of the
keynote people right because it's like
okay it's up to you like can you get
these people excited can you make sure
that they're holding their attention can
you keep them entertained can you keep
this thing moving
on time all that kind of stuff right it
was pretty cool so
anyway that was really gratifying cool i
really want to do more of that like that
kind of busted my cherry with that type
of work and i have such a whole new
level of respect for people that host
because i think it's easy to look at you
know i don't know people that that host
like reality tv shows and the like and
just be like you know they just read you
know they're reading off teleprompter
how hard can it be like the bachelorette
yeah like well i called my friend asher
gunsberg who hosts the bachelor in
australia and i was like because i was
having a panic moment
i was like dude i got to do this thing
tomorrow and i just realized like it's
so much more intense than i thought it
would be right and i only have so much
time to get ready like you gotta you
gotta talk me through this and he spent
a couple hours with me on the phone and
it was incredibly helpful he gave me all
of these
tips and tools because he's been doing
it for like 25 years
i was really interesting race guy jeff
probst yeah right yeah i could see you
as i mean
it's it's a it's a cool thing like i i
was very dismissive of the whole thing
until i did it and i was like wow this
is like a lot
right yeah props props to anybody who
hosts stuff yeah so that was very cool
and
i had gone to miami a couple days
earlier so i could get some swimming in
and prep for this race got a bunch of
cool open water
swims under my belt including one the
final day i had i shared this on social
media and i talked to you about it right
i was out i was probably
a little bit too offshore like miami
beach it stays pretty shallow right
until you get pretty far out and i was a
little bit choppier than i would have
liked so i wanted to get past the break
but it was still only i was probably
like 200 meters offshore okay we're
still only like maybe eight feet deep
right so it's not like oh man i'm out at
open sea or anything like that it's all
very manageable um swimming along
and then four five foot lemon sharks
swam just beneath me like right along
the bottom yeah which was super cool
uh
but also you know it's like dude they're
sharks they're right there sharks look
like sharks
and i know that lemon sharks are not the
most aggressive uh and i found myself
much calmer in the situation that i
would have predicted i was like okay i
should probably get a little bit closer
to shore and just kind of calmly pivoted
toward shore
and it's not like any of them even
noticed me or anything like that well
they probably noticed you but they
didn't right but they don't give a [ __ ]
right right which is that's and they go
close to shore too i mean that's that
200 it's not like they're staying at 200
do you know much about lemon sharks no
would you like me to google
well live right
i mean my understanding i mean they're
not innocuous like they they have
attacked people i don't think i don't
know i've never killed i don't know if
they've ever killed him
it's so rare for people to get even bit
it's crazy rare
you know it's it's insane but they
weren't small i mean they were like the
length of the they can get 11 feet they
can get they can get those are probably
juveniles they can just and they look
like you know
like what a shirt it's not like they
look different than what you would
expect sharks always look so sharky
don't they
they can be counted on something the
funky kind of like port that's we've
just found the title of this podcast
sharks can look so sharp i mean leopard
shots that's the quote graphic that
we're going to use like nurse sharks
have the little like catfish thing oh
that makes you realize that whale sharks
still look sharky but that you know they
don't bite you but uh everything from
reef shark up uh looks so sharky let's
see what it says what does it eat
it eats
ultra athletes that wrote books
that's a very small loves podcasters
people um um
yeah they eat crustaceans
you know they're not eating they're not
eating humans i know so that was a cool
experience i'd never had i've never been
out in the water and seen a shark in the
wild never no what about in hawaii
you've never seen it never seen reef
sharks dolphins but never no really
maybe tiny little sharks that i don't
even remember but nothing that was like
wow that's a that's a legit
a legit group of sharks right there yeah
yeah you know
in any event the conference that i was
at
was just prior to the bitcoin conference
okay which is what brings like that was
like a big deal so i left like the day
before that started but i have a bunch
of friends that are bitcoiners who came
into town early so i was able to see
one or two of them and you guys hit the
clubs it made me no like but my i have
this friend peter mccormick yeah
who has the biggest bitcoin podcast it's
called what bitcoin did
and he came on one of our retreats to
italy several years ago
and i he had this idea uh of starting a
bitcoin podcast and i kind of helped him
get it up on his feet and now he's like
the man in bitcoin like he he ended up
like hosting essentially like a full day
of the conference like he's a big name
in that world and it made me think like
oh maybe peter would be a good guest
like i've never had anyone on to talk
about bitcoin yeah that's a good idea um
i have a lot we've attempted to talk
about nft yeah i i i you know i'm the
furthest thing from an expert on crypto
no but it ain't going away and that
bitcoin conference was a big deal
you know what my favorite thing about
crypto is
the larry david commercial that you
don't have any of it no the larry david
i do have some oh is that the super bowl
commercial one yeah i can't remember
whether i saw that or not oh yeah it's
great we'll we'll link it in the show
notes
there's a long form on youtube um
uh
i uh yeah no i do own some bitcoin not
bitcoin
some lesser-known cryptos
some weird crypto coin
all right why is that
no i own some lesser known i don't know
i haven't quite taken off yet i i own
like a negligible amount of bitcoin like
like a quarter of a coin
oh less than that a quarter of a coin
would be i mean bitcoin's at 40 grand
right now okay so a quarter of a coin
would be 10 full grand yeah it would be
10 grand okay
i don't have that
larry ellison if you're listening you
can put that 25 straight into a bitcoin
right percentage your wallet your
bitcoin what your crypto wallet in my
crypto wallet not yours larry um but
here's the thing
i returned from florida with covid
which is interesting because i thought i
thought covett didn't exist in florida
but maybe that's why i didn't start to
experience symptoms until i was on the
plane home i like that joke but rich i
think it's good you left miami with a
communicative disease like you should
have right
i mean i interacted with hundreds of
people yeah it was spring break the
bitcoiners were coming in
well spring like you're in these hotels
at miami beach and it's like
like at the pools all day long and all
night you can't escape it and the music
let's you know what i like dance music i
like this is where i'm an old man yeah
i'm like i like dancing i like music i
like the old i like the disco house the
old stuff
this crap this like miami version
it's
remarkable what's interesting is that in
miami everywhere you go that's the
soundtrack i went to the um time out
food court like timeout builds these
food courts all over the world with like
and they're pretty cool spaces and i had
they built one on lincoln road in miami
and i'd never
seen it or been to it i was like i'm
going to go check it out and i walked in
and it was like
like so loud in there
that i did a loop and just walked out i
was like i can't i can't eat in here oh
that was the dinner soundtrack no it was
in the middle of the day what let me let
me hear what was the soundtrack it's
just you know like come on all right
anyway
what what hotel did you stay in
uh i was at the w is the standard still
there because they closed here the
standard there was there but the delano
which was kind of like the og hot spot
this is closed down right now and that
used to be the furthest north that
anybody would go in south beach before
it kind of got gnarly
now it goes quite a bit further north
but there's still you know it's like
it's an interesting spot like i like
miami i think
i think miami has some charms some
people don't like it because it looks
like shallow on the surface i like that
it's like this panama great pan american
city probably the only pan american city
where people from all over latin america
live it's a true bilingual city
it's um it's got great uh cuban and just
latin
latino food in general mexican cuban
whatever everything's there yeah and if
you're there and you want to eat
plant-based you got to go to love life
okay in wynwood so our friends diego and
veronica own this restaurant they're
geniuses it is the best
plant-based restaurant i've ever been
really and that's like i say that like
i've been to a lot of places i'm gonna
get a lot of phone calls and tests i
know i love it
they're so good diego's recipes are
incredible
i love it i shared it no they don't have
a cookbook i think one of the recipes is
going to be in
in dan buettner's next book okay which
is coming out soon oh cool and they're
making some cool moves that that aren't
public yet but i'll be sharing about
something
i love them living outside yeah that's
my recommendation
um
love life
in wynwood good stuff but anyway yeah i
came back i came back with go but that's
why there was no roll on last week right
uh which is you know we would have
typically done it then how was it for
you
it was pretty mild you know i was
vaccinated
so within a couple days i was kind of
over it i didn't lose my taste i didn't
lose my smell i had
two nights where i experienced some form
of fever and chills so for 48 hours just
at night i got like you know shivery or
whatever
and then basically just kind of achy and
weak for a couple days
and then it passed so did you isolate
somewhere in the house i isolated in my
tent you stayed in this so i was like
the english patient you were like
tyler was joking he's like
it's like it's like it's
and you're recovering from consumption
in the backyard the only problem is it
was like 95 degrees out so the tent got
way too hot in the middle of the day for
me to convalesce right but yeah i
isolated um
and everybody else in the family is fine
i basically just hydrated slept rested i
did do a five day course of paxlovid
which is an antiviral that was
recommended to me
and i think that probably expedited how
quickly i got over it in addition to
that
i took a lot of
supplements i took about 40 000 iuds of
vitamin d every day vitamin c vitamin k
quercetin curcumin on top of what i
typically take which is just a
multivitamin athletic greens b12 and
stuff like that so so your pe was like
rainbow color it was very yeah it was
very yellow it was very yellow um but
three and a half days in i was pretty
much fine uh i had talked to a bunch of
athletes who were cautioning me not to
get back into any kind of training and
to really take my time with it
because it can snap back on you right
i've had friends that have taken three
weeks off
but i felt like
five days
in i was like i felt completely fine so
i went back to the pool at on day six i
think for a light swim and i've just
been slowly building since then but i
feel 100 now nice but i did miss i think
seven days of training
uh so in the context of training for
this you know long open water swim that
is not too
far away in the future uh that you know
definitely set me back
seems like you're rocking it though from
instagram stories okay it's been nice to
just be in the pool and focus on
swimming every day because during all of
the ultra endurance races that i
trained for i would only swim two or
three days a week right the focus was on
other stuff so it's been decades since i
just focused on swimming and kind of
swam pretty much every day and
it feels good i feel strong and getting
stronger every day you look great
thank you sir yeah thank you yes
um what else we got a quick little piece
of housekeeping before we move into the
next thing matthew walker who was in
miami i talked to him about coming back
on the podcast oh cool and i think what
we want to do is an ama formatted
conversation that's obviously specific
to sleep
we haven't scheduled it yet but we'll be
doing that at some point in the spring
or the summer and i thought it would be
good to just make the announcement now
if you have a sleep question you can
submit that on our voicemail at
424-235-4626
or you can send an email to rrpstudio
ritual.com so sleep questions only to
that email from matthew walker we'll go
through all the questions of course find
the best ones and kind of do a very
structured sleep oriented conversation
i'm really not that great at sleep if
matthew cares to tinker with me or in
any way i think matthew cares deeply
adam yeah he seems like a caring guy he
is yeah he's a wonderful wonderful man
yeah um all right well let's do our
endurance sports check-in we got a lot
of i know let's do it where do you want
to start robbie ballinger of course john
henry or as i call john henry 2.0 or as
i call him don juan henry john
he is very charming with that mustache
very swarthy don juan um the idea was
that he was going to outlast a tesla
yeah tesla i think there's a lot of
people who don't know
you pronounce it tesla as opposed to
what tesla tesla tesla tesla tesla like
a z with a z vibe on it that's what you
guess what you said i don't know i'm not
even consciously aware of how i'm
pronouncing it
my point though is that you throw the
name john henry out like everybody knows
who that is people don't know who john
henry is
there might be a lot of people out there
who are less studied in
in american history so spell it out john
henry uh it was this period of time when
um basically people were were building
the roads and and getting through
mountains so they were using
p they would blow it up and then people
would kind of go in with a pickaxe and
and
like hack their way through mountains
um and then the steam engine was
invented and john henry was the greatest
of them all he was the guy that could be
could he did the work of 20 men there's
like folk songs about him yeah he was
like the david goggins of road engineers
he was he was he was the workhorse of be
beyond like he was like you know 50 men
he ate like you know
10 steaks for breakfast kind of thing i
forget what it was but he um
and he was like revered
um and this steam engine came along and
promised to put him all out of work and
so john henry was challenged to
challenge to beat the steam engine i
think he did it for his fellow workers
you know let's let's show this this
engine
who's boss and the coal powered steam
engine versus john henry and john henry
was in a race but it was a timed race
and john henry beats the steam engine
and basically like dies
like uh drilling through
the side of a mountain right type and uh
and then he dies at the finish line um
but he wins there's a great book called
john henry days by colson whitehead who
i've name dropped on this podcast a few
times before it's one of his first books
it's i think it's his second or third um
very very very funny very poignant it's
excellent uh and so john henry days but
uh and i actually recommended that to
robbie in case he was interested right
yeah well not to spoil it ravi did not
die no at the end of his challenge and
it wasn't timed it wasn't timed and he
did technically outlast the tesla
although he didn't meet his his kind of
time goal so
basically this tesla starts out
um on the outskirts of of austin and
drives until it has a full battery
charge and drives until the battery dies
it goes 242 miles and ravi's challenge
was to
run that distance from where the tesla
started in under 72 hours
he succeeded in
in running the full 242 miles it took
him a little bit longer just under 77
hours
um and i think you know the heat and
humidity of of the texas hill country
crazy like an average of 93 degrees
fahrenheit
um plus 13 000 feet of elevation gain we
think of texas as flat but they did it
in the hill country so lots of ups and
downs um was you know
it it
it it laid the pain on him it's a lot of
miles um and i had serious fomo watching
this because i was invited to attend and
support and i really wanted to but i had
just gotten back from miami and didn't
feel like i could leave town again plus
i had kovitz so i couldn't have gone
even if i had agreed to do it
so i just watched it on instagram like
everybody else but what was cool is so
many cool people and friends of the
podcast were there to support robbie we
had hella was there hella hella sidibe
of course
dan churchill who hasn't been on the
podcast but is a good friend of mine he
is the uh owner and head chef at charlie
street in new york city just an amazing
dude uh a guy that everybody should
follow on um
on uh
on instagram he shares recipes and
training stuff super positive
fit dude australian contributor to chris
hemsworth center app
um oh really i love this guy and he's an
incredible athlete as well
so i pulled up his uh blake you can pull
up his there it is there's his page so
dan underscore churchill he's very
photogenic he's very handsome and
charming yeah and positive must be nice
wonderful wonderful guy
robbie of course is robbie ballinger on
instagram there's his page if you're
watching on youtube so he was sharing of
course you know images and videos along
the way
um but here's the idea basically outlast
to tesla and he did he did it um
we had hella there as well
here's hella with uh another guy who
showed up support robbie william gooch
googe
who robbie supported when william
ran the circumference of the you i think
he ran around the united kingdom yeah um
like a year ago and ravi went out to
crew for him and support him he's an
incredible athlete very unique human
being he ran like 48 marathons in 30
days crazy and then in the week like
prior to robbie's challenge
he did marathon to saab
uh and he shared all his whoop scores
like i think whoop posted a bunch of
stuff like on their website maybe i can
find a link to that and then like a day
later he went to zurich and ran a
marathon there and then he flew to
austin did the robbie thing
and uh and then he went like straight to
coachella
now he's like a hype beast and coachella
like this guy like he wears gold chains
he's very like he's like a hype beast
um
and there's something like kind of cool
i like that the baggy sweats are back i
noticed i mean he's a style master yes
dude like you know check him out but
like a beast of an athlete and it was
cool that ravi supported him and then he
flew all the way you know basically
halfway around the world to support
robbie here's william
at mds oh nice looking like a fashion
model good out on the sand
um anyway really cool congrats to robbie
for his latest adventure that was uh you
mean don juan henry don juan henry
supported by 10 000 of course uh that
works with um
dan churchill and i yes another you know
a group of really cool athletes so it
was kind of a 10 000 sponsored challenge
it was yeah and it was cool to see what
what robbie does next
at one point it looked like he was real
shaky like he could move if you if he
was moving he was fine but like
like getting up from his um support
vehicle and getting back on his feet man
there were times where he was like he
was real wobbly yeah yeah super wobbly
and then he was running like no problem
then he was fine yeah and that's the way
these ultras are you look like oh
there's no this guy's done you know
there's no way he can't even walk
and then a couple hours later or night
falls
gets a little bit cooler out get some
calories and some food a little bit of a
nap and then all of a sudden it's a new
human amazing so that's good on you
robbie sorry i wasn't there to support
you we love you though and it's uh
it's cool to see you continue to inspire
people all over the world 100 um but
robbie plays a big part in the next
uh dispatch from the world of endurance
that we're going to talk about today yes
the you mean oz's central park loop
record yeah yeah the o's pearlman record
yeah
um you know if you if you have not uh
seen i mean i i feel like your
listeners and our listener our listeners
i feel like they're hourly own it our
listeners
um are aware of what happened you were
you were uh
instagramming about it tweeting about it
um
o's pearlman owes the mentalist who is
just recently a guest on this here
program
wanted to set the record for the fkt for
most loops around central park he ended
up doing 19 loops 116 miles a day in a
day and the
it's important to know 18 hours 50
minutes yeah they don't it's only the
part that loop is only open during
certain hours of that like 6 a.m to 1
a.m or something right that's right 6 am
and you can't you can't start till 605
and you have to finish at 12 55. so he
gives you 18.50 when um and he's
breaking robbie's record robbie did 16
loops
and and he robbie held the second fkt so
it's not that like it's been around a
long time it started in uh 2020 someone
laid down uh i believe was 12 loops
loops it's in the article aaron zolhafer
i believe is his name and by the article
you must be referring to the new york
times article that you wrote yes so i
was i was lucky enough to be able to
cover it so i knew o's was going to go
for this oh you know the back story of
the whole article
is
that uh
david goggins invited me to a zoom at
the beginning of the pandemic when oz
was like having to transition his
business from live shows to zoom
and i'd heard of o's before but i hadn't
really
um
you know
i wasn't really that acquainted with
with how great he was
and i sat in on this zoo and i zoom and
i saw him predict like the the serial
numbers on some dollar bill in some
dude's wallet like 2000 miles away from
him through zoom and i i realized wow
this guy's amazing and then quickly
after that i found out he was a great
runner and so i stayed in contact with
him uh just mostly instagram messaging
and then i you know said if there's ever
an event he's going to tackle let me
know because i think it would be a cool
story and he was going to do last summer
montauk to manhattan
170 miles but it didn't didn't end up
happening and so i'd already gotten new
york times sports interested in that and
then he called he called me like two
weeks before this so three weeks ago now
two weeks before this and said what do
you think of me doing this and i said i
think that's great and so i talked to
my editor who's in charge of endurance
and adventure sports at new york times
her name is talia minsberg
and we talked about o's and she quickly
got on board and and so i did it you
know at first i said
you're the new york times at central
park like i can't get there
and you don't need me there you have a
whole op you have a whole office of
reporters really good ones why don't you
just do it i i wasn't even going to do
it and well that's how i present
positioned it but um
it turns out she wanted me to do it so i
ended up having to report it remotely
but hillary swift who did amazing
photographs she was also kind of my eyes
and ears so we stayed in contact i was
obviously watching him on instagram i
facetimed with him i called him i text
everything so i had full access but it
was interesting that it was a remote
story and you talked to robbie also i
talked to robbie beforehand so i
interviewed uh o's and robbie
the week before
and so that was cool as my first chance
to really talk to robbie and understand
what he's about so he's in he's
mentioned in there
um the best story that's not in there is
is uh there's a guy named george a
hirsch have you ever heard of george a
hirsch he's the chairman of the new york
road runners he's like 87 years old i
believe
and he uh
he also is a giant in publishing he he
started new york magazine he went on to
become the global edit first global
editor of men's health so
uh yeah and
so head of head of men's health started
a new york magazine also a giant in in
running not only is he now the acting
chairman of new york road runners he is
the founder of the five borough new york
marathon wow so he changed that whole
course and was an early runner like in
the 60s he's running around nobody's
running
um anyway so he became friends with os
many years ago
and uh so he knew about you know he's
he's he's known him for a long time and
at one point
when his wife was in the hospital she
died of cancer and when she was in the
hospital after like a treatment went bad
os was out on a long run
and stopped by and you could tell he was
running he stopped by to lift her
spirits because they'd had dinner they
were close
and uh he comes in and says to his way
you know he does a whole he does a whole
thing with his wife to lift her spirits
and at one point he's like
this is what george described he says
he says uh i want you to think of one
person
that is famous and one person who's not
and she said okay and then he goes over
to her laptop and he pulls up a picture
of bill clinton and turns it to her and
she's like of course
wow you know you know it's crazy
and then and then uh i want to get this
right so i'm going to go to then she
then he
scribbles down a note
to uh
you know and hands it to her and she
opens up the note and um let me just
make sure i get it and she opens up the
note and it's uh
it says say hello to shirley and
george's wife was named shea that's
shae's childhood best friend from idaho
shirley and so like that's the kind of
stuff he's doing and the fact that he
took his time out and he did that i
think that's amazing and i really wanted
george to be part of the story but just
wasn't enough words and so um they ended
up using
an example of what he did to me which at
mile 80 right which was you're on the
phone with him yeah he's on mile 80.
he's like running while talking to you
on the phone about facetime mm-hmm and
he's like
adam i want you to think of
uh a friend and i said okay and he goes
he said no you're not thinking if it's a
friend i could find i could i could have
researched i could you're thinking less
clearly than me and i'm at mile 80. i
want you to think of your first crush
and so i said okay thought of my first
crush then he asked me you know how many
letters were in her name
or think of how yeah no he said he said
think of her name okay then he didn't
ask me how many letters he said he said
i want you to count the letters in her
name i said okay done and he's and
that's and he goes see
now i know it's a short short name yeah
he got that right away but that still
doesn't i mean it's it was an odd name
and uh and so then you know pretty
quickly he gets it it's raw's roz it's
really remarkable how quickly he gets it
um and this is someone i haven't talked
to haven't heard from i haven't had any
contact with in decades
um so there's impossible for him to like
it's just incredible and he's he's
running
at this point i mean he did that time
and time again we just put up a video of
kind of behind the scenes of when he was
here where he's screwing around with the
with the with the team here and doing
all kinds of shenanigans and it's just
it's unbelievable yeah blake who the
hell is eamonn so that was the version
of what he did to hersh's wife yeah
right like he basically pulls this name
out of nowhere yeah
so quickly so he's a magic he's a
magical man it is wizardry yeah it's
really awesome and uh it was a lot of
fun to write it and it was it was it was
cool it was one of those one of those
stories i'll remember so if you're if
you're watching on youtube we're just
kind of sharing the new york times
article and in print it was beautiful i
mean they put all of these photographs
in there and it was a full-page deal so
that's got to be cool yeah it was cool
and yeah it was how does it work
yeah like so you submit you you get like
the green light to write this thing
right they assign a photographer even
though you're not there you do your
reporting you write the thing you turn
it in and then it goes through like a
fact checking and an editorial process
right and they strip a bunch of stuff
out of it i mean i think it depends on
the desk with sports stuff i do my own
fact checking i want it real tight so
what happens is i i report it i'll file
it
and then um depending on the quick
turnaround this one we published monday
so there wasn't like they they had they
had stuff already saturday and sunday
covered so they didn't need more stories
and so we're later than everybody else
which means you have to be better than
everybody else you have to be smarter
right so um
so we but we also had more space so we
so i file it and then um talia doesn't
edit
gets it back to me i might make some
changes
then uh she there's a second edit like a
like a copy edit top edit in that period
of time i'm doing all my fact checking
and then i uh so anything i'm not 100
certain on i will call whoever so with
o's i had to call him like three times
on one day um and then he here's the
other thing so we didn't even say what
he did he did he did 19 loops 116 miles
right crushes the record
um goes home
it's you know at that point it's like
what two in the morning or something
like that goes home grabs a couple hours
of sleep and then has a 1 p.m flight to
augusta because he's doing a show at the
masters yes the next day totally fine
and then he shares this and he's like i
feel guilty for not running today or i
feel like i need to go running he only
lost because he's on a streak i think
yeah yeah well no he took a week off you
know he took a week off okay um shout
out hillary swift the photographer she
was on a bicycle like
riding around with him all day she must
have done 50 miles on the bicycle and
she's a she's a good marathoner she's a
sub four-hour marathoner friends with
alexis and friends alexi pappas and
talia the the uh editor on this was also
just ran boston today and she's a sub
four hour marathoner so we're going to
talk about boston but let's take a quick
break and we'll be right back
prophets walk among us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years i've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so i've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why i'm proud to announce the release of
my new book
voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration
and timeless wisdom that transpires each
week on the ritual podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying stand-alone work picking
up this book allows you to revisit the
wisdom of your favorite everyday
prophets and physically interact with
the life-changing ideas contained within
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
all right and we're back we're going to
talk about boston for a couple minutes
today is monday
so boston was just run and concluded
right before we started
recording by the time anybody listens to
this it will be thursday at a minimum so
there'll be lots of articles out and
hot takes etc so i don't want to spend a
ton of time on this other than to just
kind of note a couple interesting
performances
first of all friend of the pod scott
faubel
been on the show before for a previous
amazing boston experience uh he came in
as the fastest american in seventh round
pr of 208 52 seventh fastest american of
all time and what's interesting is that
he's unsponsored right now
so he literally wore a lululemon tank
top that he bought himself off the rack
incredible she's crazy yeah right he's
gonna be sponsored now um and
interestingly he even split the race he
went from 22nd to 7th in the second half
ran 64-26
for the first half and 64-26 for the
second half which is unbelievable
fastest american man since meb in 2014.
so a burrito for you sir that's his
thing burritos we love you scott
congratulations there were a lot of eyes
on this athlete
cj albertson
he ended up being the third american ran
at 210
his pr
um and the reason there's a lot of eyes
on him is that he kind of uh he led
boston last year for the first
um
i don't know 21 miles or something like
that yeah i think 21 miles he led the
race he's a rabbit he loves to be super
aggressive and he's been sharing his his
workouts on strava and he's just an
absolute maniac so everyone's like this
guy's gonna crush it based on what he
was posting in this public forum um his
final long run leading into boston was a
22-mile run where he averaged
five-minute pace so he's a beast and he
sprinted like right off the start
of of boston and like lead immediately
and like really you know aggressively
kind of forced
um the lead pack into you know a pace
that was probably uncomfortable for most
so good for him that's cool on the
women's side evans chabette uh
won for the men
right yeah we should have you should
have noted who actually won the race
correctly thank you and congrats to him
yes on the women's side
olympic and new york city marathon
champion perez jep churchill
i hope i'm pronouncing that right from
kenya one
uh it was an epic final mile duel with
the half marathon world record holder
abba bell yesterday oh really i'm
pronouncing that as well from ethiopia
um
perez ran 22101 second fastest ever at
boston yesterday ran 221.05 so just four
seconds separating them wow their final
mile was a 523 mile that's how fast
these women were running that's amazing
um but just of of kind of personal
interest uh 42 year old edna kipligott
got fourth running 221 destroying your
own master's record 42 years old 221
that's unbelievable
nel rojas was the top american with a
225 57 performance um among the other
kind of american women who who
who were getting a lot of attention
stephanie ross dean bruce
um rana 228 dez linden front of the
podcast
was the third american she ran 228 molly
seidel there was a lot of eyes on her
and she ended up dropping out did she
not even toe up no she towed up and i
can't remember at what point she dropped
out i mean again i just glanced at
results in twitter quickly before we
started recording so
my um
my take is half baked at this point okay
cool i do know that knox robinson of
course was there running because he goes
to every cool marathon alexi pappas
interestingly ran as uh a guide to a
blind athlete lisa thompson that's
pretty cool
um and also and this is kind of a story
that's a bit aside that i've been
tracking and paying attention to
ultra runner and amputee jackie hunt
brosma and i hope i'm pronouncing her
last name correct um
rant also ran boston it was the 91st
consecutive marathon that she's run
she's on pace to set a new world record
uh 92 days into her goal to run 102
marathons in as many days which is
pretty cool amazing so i think boston
was was it day nine maybe it was day 92
i'm not sure have you run boston uh i
have not how many marathons have you run
none really oh you haven't done life
i did no i did the long beach marathon
like early in my ultra career and was
humbled by that and that's the only
legitimate like marathon that i've ever
do you ever want to run new york i know
you love new york well i i did i got a
charity slot for new york this year i've
got to heal my back though because i'm
not running at all right now but i'd
love to be able to go and participate in
the new york city marathon in the fall
we'll see
um let's talk about st george let's do
it
what about it i i i'm a little you i
threw the ball to you
you're fumbling a little bit
come on this is your jam dude you've
you've been following the norwegians i
have
i thought you were going to go to saint
george and be i would say i was before i
was supposed to
go to saint george at one point but um
it's just not going to happen for me
unfortunately um but i'm really excited
to see what christian blumenfeldt can do
and and some of the other guys gustav um
eden as well um the norwegians are ready
to drop the hammer but it does seem like
this race is
lost a little shine for me i was excited
to see lucy charles barclay who won the
half out there the world championship
and she was kind of like rounding in a
form of feeling really good about her
form i interviewed her um for that same
story i did um on christian and the the
norwegians and um so she felt you know
she was like really confident then and
to have a fracture like that in the hip
is unfortunate because it seems like
that could take a little while um and
then jan fordino who i also interviewed
for that story was very excited to see
run um he also
is yeah i heard that he's out but why is
he out what happened to him
um i didn't i didn't uh follow up on
that unfortunately i'm sorry it's been
very busy i've been busy adam i'm sorry
you're working on a top secret secret
project that we'll be able to talk about
soon yeah yeah yeah yeah but i was you
know he's 42 years old so like you want
but i think that having talked having
spoken to him
most likely he's gearing up his year you
know when you're i think he everything
orients for him to the north star of
kona and so i know that he wants to do
kona and i know he reveres conan i know
he wasn't really super stoked with the
idea of racing outside of kona right so
just for people that don't know this
saint george iron man is taking place on
may 7th and it's been set up
utah as uh an ironman world championship
right because of covid and all these
other last years last year's right yeah
because they couldn't do it and they
cancelled it in kona because they didn't
feel like if there was if if there had
been an outbreak they would not have
been able to handle it on that island
the island was like basically saying we
don't think you should do it and it kind
of stopped so this is last year's world
championship but kona will still is
scheduled to take place in october
same yeah
so it's still supposed to happen they're
not they're not divorcing from kona by
any means but they're they're interested
in seeing iron man as a brand is
interested in seeing what's going to
transpire will this like maybe people
won't miss it maybe they can travel
every other year from kona to cities
around the world because europe is such
is is kind of where the sport's
happening now anyway you know it's so
funny because when it really started
california like san diego
santa cruz mark allen uh hawaii like
that was the epicenter of of triathlon
um some australians too but mostly it
was like san diego north county san
diego that's really where the heartbeat
of the whole thing and then boulder came
into it but but um but it was always
really north american focus and if you
look at now the rankings and all the big
athletes it's european folks so to be
able to take everyone i think this st
george is setting them up to maybe see
hey can we do it in berlin can we do can
we make it a more interesting thing for
the sport right um which i like that
idea but then to come back every other
year to kona that's how it was kind of
told to me i like that idea i think it
is important to shake this up a little
bit and try to make it more interesting
there is something you know epic about
the legacy of kona and kona is what it
is um but frankly
you know it's not that interesting of a
course like you're on the ground going
uh it's like i've spent a lot of time on
the big island i've done a lot of riding
on the queen k after you've done it a
couple times you're like is there
anywhere else to ride like right i think
that the sport would benefit from mixing
it up
putting the world championships every
other year in a different
setting with a different type of course
that would favor or disadvantage a
different type of athlete to really make
it interesting well that's what's
interesting about this course it's going
to be hillier
the cycling will be different uh the the
swimming you're swimming in a lake
versus the warm sea uh may is not always
hot in st george so it's it'll be
interesting to see um and i yeah i agree
with you like the cinematics of imagine
doing a race and you know moving it
around like paris or or uh you know
tokyo or whatever it is um
uh i think that that there is an appeal
there um
but we'll see how it goes and uh but i
am kind of bummed that these two big
stars are out you're always bummed when
the two big stars are out but i think
really it was always going to come down
will the norwegian experience experiment
work you know will they will they have a
world iron man champion yeah well what's
cool is that there has been some [ __ ]
talking going on um if you want to be on
top of that the best follow on twitter
is brad culp who's a journalist in the
triathlon space he's at bbculp on
twitter um and he tweeted the other day
triathlon needs rivalries and a few
weeks ago
joe skipper who's uh
a british pro he's uh the uk iron man
champion
started talking a little bit of smack
about the norwegians and you know don't
believe the norwegian hype train yes
yeah you know yeah and when we talk
about the norwegians what we're really
talking about is christian blumenfeld
and gustav eden
who are just crushing it right now and
what's great is that uh there's this
there's this training uh video on
youtube it's uh it's gustav and
christian on a track with snow
everywhere throwing down like insane
intervals in sierra nevada
yeah at altitude yeah right and you're
just hauling ass
and at about 10 40 or something into
this video we'll share it for those on
youtube
christian's got a little bit of a
response
here he is
he he just dusted gustav on this set
pulling away from him
whatever you do
don't believe it
[Laughter]
a little uh reverse psychology from the
norwegian hype train he looks great this
is norwegian hype train is looking good
if i was a betting man i'm not betting
against these guys i mean me neither i i
think i think he's already shown what he
can do at the distance uh christian and
gustav has too quite frankly he had a
very fast race as well
the source of this is sorry to interrupt
you the source of this is that you know
look christian's only he did cozumel but
he's not that experienced at iron man
fair and you know and he didn't give her
something over his head here he didn't
have a great half in st george correct
so
we'll see all right well we'll report
back on that in the wake of may 7th
um we got to talk about the rollies
the rolly winners do you remember a
couple weeks ago when we announced the
nominees for the first annual rollies do
i remember
yes no you don't remember blanked it out
completely you know how i feel like
people have received the rollies they're
like my parents who by the way are
devout devout listeners now of yours
yeah how did they feel about the rollies
my dad didn't really wasn't really
thrilled by them my mother really liked
them and i think that's kind of like
yeah 50 50 right it was an interesting
response like yeah
i mean a lot of people were like
come on man really you're going to waste
my time with this my time is limited but
we we we introduced them saying like
we're gonna now waste your time yeah
yeah with a bunch of nonsense i mean so
tune out or enjoy i mean it's
interesting it's your choice it's
entertainment right yeah that's what
we're doing are we entertaining i'm not
sure
we're somewhere are we wasting your time
probably we're infotainment okay
so
we're knee deep in this so we have to
see it through are you committed now
though
i'm committed so we're doing year two
i'm committed so for year two we also
have to come up with a trophy i agree
yeah or trophies i think you're just
assuming we have special guests yeah i
think that would be good we could have a
lot of hype leading up to who the
nominees are going to be we nominate
maybe we don't nominate on we could
dominate roll on contact we don't
nominate on the air we do a extended
rollies
uh for the winners we don't know
all right well we got a report back
on who the winners are and what's great
about this google form thank you to
everybody who voted they come back
actually
like yeah we got like pie charts
we got analytics on this whole thing
it's unbelievable so
i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this let's rifle through it let's do it
first category best endurance
performance in an rrp supporting role
who lobbied for this award the hardest
we all know who did it was jason camiolo
he wanted it badly he posted about it on
social media he courted voters who knows
what else he was doing sending checks
out holding cocktail parties you're
rolling a full miramax camp game
he changed his his avatar on instagram
to the rolly symbol it worked this is
how bad he wanted it and you know what
he shall be duly rewarded because he
walked away with 49.7 percent of the
vote to be the 2021
victor
category of best endurance performance
in an rrp supporting role
congratulations congratulations jason i
wish we had a trophy for you it was
actually jason's idea that we get a
trophy i think he wanted it for himself
we didn't get it together in time maybe
we can do it posted optimistically i'd
like to just for the record say i voted
for everyone but me blake i think i i
was one of your two votes
yeah so uh davey came in second with 22
percent 22.6 percent of the vote
um then we've got uh adam yeah you got
22.3
poor blake
courteous blake gentleman blake yeah
we'll have to work on that for next year
but i think blake blake blake's
impressive arc in becoming a competitive
athlete
is not being duly uh i noticed there's
an argument that blake is the best
athlete i think that probably is true
yeah and the most diverse yeah but
we'll have to wait for another year but
that doesn't matter but the pressure is
on the staff
to really up their game for the
following year i see this category just
getting more and more competitive i see
my resume not changing at all
you could be the constant yeah i'll do
the same three things every year um all
right next category best endurance
performance of the year by an rrp guest
yes
the nominees were hella sidibe robbie
ballinger courtney dewalter harvey lewis
leah goldstein yarn cowboy timothy olson
lewis pugh and jason caldwell walking
away with victory with 42
42.9 of the vote is
drum roll we need sound effects jason
uh the iron cowboy yeah well deserved
congratulations james
moving on we have a lot of categories to
get through here yes coolest person of
2021
the nominees were johnny greenwood
rafael nadal
beau burnham
nirmal persia
and billy
with 28.7 of the vote this year is
one billy eilish it's not really fair
headlining coachella this past weekend
by the way yeah i mean i mean billy and
rafa are like two legit stars kind of
yeah
i feel like johnny greenwood didn't get
enough love i know that was yours 6.1
he got so little that there wasn't
enough room to actually write the
percentage in his little slices where
did you when did you have time to vote
for him 48 times rich yeah i know right
i didn't vote you know i stayed out of
this um here you want to handle this
next one best limited series about
narcissistic self-mythologizing
aka scammers scammer series or founder
television i guess right yes foundation
my favorite category but i'm handing it
over to you okay super pumped we crashed
the dropout inventing anna bad vegan and
the winner is
bad vegan with 35.7 percent of the vote
very interesting
on that one not the uh
not the best of that group but i guess
given the subject matter and interest of
our particular audience it's not
surprising but inventing anna came in
the second even though it's it's not
that great of a show but that shows the
popularity of the show that's so
interesting and by the way like drop out
is the best
is the best of all of these but the
hardest term quality yes hardest time
yeah inventing anna is garbage didn't i
say that last time you did but but i
guess the audience disagrees how many
people disagree with you yeah yeah
um but maybe the best at
self-mythologizing
i don't know anyway all right next
category
we've got to keep this moving i'm a host
these days right most i am keeping this
film of 2021 the alpinist 14 peaks don't
look up roadrunner the rescue dopesick
and the winner is with thirty one point
eight percent of the votes
fourteen peaks nims with a win
was nominated for two rows closer um
with don't look up and dopesick uh
pretty close on the heels yeah but i i
like that this is like one of those he's
walking up and say uh nims was nominated
for two rollies this year and he came
home with one that's right
uh best book by an rrp guest in 2021
another hotly contested competitive
category
we got bravey think again why we sleep
dopamine nation regeneration your turn
the awakened brain stolen focus and
transcendence
and the winner is adam bravey by alexi
pappas audience favorite of course
everybody loves the legends where's the
where's somebody i said
jason
come on yeah i know right so we need
like that little button drop with a
little applause you know and also the
music that like cues us off stage the
little symphonic like little ditty you
need that actually my favorite
categories coming up it had a lot of
responses yeah this was your i'll let
you do this one because this was your
this you came up with this category
should we we're gonna have to revamp
these put a little more thought i think
categories next year
yeah i don't know what we're doing okay
best ritual novo obsession sprouting
weight lifting
decoding the gurus ice baths and adam's
swim mask now this one
this must be very gratifying for you
buy a landslide
the
biggest obsession the most rewarded
obsession of the audience is adam's swim
master yes with a with a with an
incredible 47.7
of the votes
people can't get enough of the swim mask
in fact when i posted pictures of me
swimming in florida people were outraged
that i was not wearing the mask that you
gifted me
where was the mask
have i ever expressed any interest in
wearing a swim mask while i'm open water
swimming no i have not it's your
birthday that gift i appreciate it it
was symbolic i could put it in like a
lucite case and keep it in my opinion
but i probably will never swim with it
when you when you set up the ritual
museum
then i think that's where it belongs and
i think given the the way that the
audience voted on this that will be the
thing people will be most interested in
seeing of anything that we've ever done
in the history it'll be great it'll be
like your mask and then my mask might
have to be all corroded and used your
mask will be pristine as if you could
just it's never been used right but
among the many other artifacts signed
books by luminaries or whatever you know
knickknacks that we've collected over
the years as a as a result of hosting
this show yeah
the swim mask will be the thing the low
tech that that will go on the epitaph
you know like of the show my swim mask
won a rolly i learned
but my sweat mask want to roll right
what do we make of that like that we
could dissect that into an interesting
narrative yes um all right next category
luckiest rocker of all time all right
this is this is a garbage category this
was your idea
uh the nominees were pringles stars
and again
so
okay
when you when
the first mention of ringo starr got
forty one point four percent yeah yeah
the the second mention of ringo got 42.5
so ringo walking away with a whopping uh
80 84 percent of the vote yeah that's a
play and and once again my george
harrison theory does not hold water
uh
jason's clapping back here
i i you should be rooting for the
drummer mike let's put this in the
rearview mirror all right uh the
dystopia you would most want to live in
yeah
the nominees are dune
station 11 don't look up and squid game
interesting and the victory goes
to dune
45.5
of the vote would you rather live like
with the giant worm trying to swallow
you whole all the time see here's what i
think people don't get when they're
voting for this they all imagine
themselves as the hero in dune
but they're not the you're most of us
are not the hero we're the people you're
like you're like the slave
troops
so you got to think of yourself that way
driving the mining craft yeah yeah and
then and and uh being victimized by the
bene jesuit totally you don't want to be
victimized by the ben and jen it's
surprising that station 11 only got 25.4
percent of the vote i i chalked that up
that people just haven't watched it yet
because clearly that is the optimal
dystopia that you want to live in no
like chicago you don't want to live in
that distance but if you survive it
then you're fine and you can go
like about your merry way as a
shakespearean actor
maybe i i didn't have quite a sunny
reaction
i think but there is something
communitarian about it and celebratory
about trying to you know find
find meaning in your life in this post
virus
and they love shakespeare they do oh
yeah and they seem to be they seem to
actually be enjoying themselves all
right what if as long as they're not
getting killed uh best performance by an
ice cream scooper in a leading role this
is another skullman category
you know i don't what i don't what do i
even say about this like thank you two
nominees the cold stone guy or adam at
ben and jerry thank you adam's
being crowned with his first rolly
victory
i mean what are we even doing here why
are we wasting people thank you thank
you folks thanks for just streaming
series the nominees white lotus station
11 the north water severance and
succession
succession oh actually no uh white lotus
winning with 35.1
severance which has taken my top spot
actually behind station eleven i love
station eleven but this is an open
uh uh season finale was unbelievable if
you haven't watched that i know i kind
of lost interest i heard i got to go
back again it's an extraordinary
achievement that show you got to check
it out shout out to ben stiller
unbelievable um work from him and his
team on that project
uh best film content period series film
whatever
adam you want to listen
for inside
denis villanueva
uh the north water severance station 11
and rich's stealth tick tock account
why is that even a that got 23.5 percent
more than my favorite show the north
water coming in with a dismal 6.7 that
wasn't your favorite show your favorite
show just you just said two shows you
liked better you're right i've got lots
of favorites the north water though i
mean come on you know what richard that
show is unbelievable richard skolnick is
now inter he hated the rollies but he
was very interested in your north water
uh-huh so is he watching he's gonna
watch it yeah all right good hopefully
see the rollies do help um but bo
burnham walks away with a rolly with
30.4 percent he's a genius
he is let's give it up for him um honor
rolling lifetime achievement award for
artists working film profile there's no
vote here frank guerilla was the guy on
a roll i
uh last category
most overrated overrated overhyped film
of 2021 there was only one category here
the matrix resurrections so it walked
home with 100 of the vote well you know
it didn't make a lot of sense that the
hero of the revolution would then opt
back into the matrix right let's just
create a better matrix that's how that
thing panned out yeah oh anyway all
right all right we did it so you can be
mad if you're still with us but you know
we had to see it through we had to see
it through and based on that i'm not
sure year two is going to happen but it
could
yeah i know right
it could we'll see i'm sure we'll be on
the receiving end of some some
responses both tepid and enthusiastic
um what do we want to talk about next
couple of things i want to mention um
the first is see wait see what happened
there what
i tried to then get into it i'm trying
to i can't
i am throwing it to you sorry yes no
this is bill spindle i want to be a
generous co-host adam no sorry i
interrupted you well while i'm
interrupting you again
people get really mad that i interrupt
you too much i think it's a i interrupt
i do and i plead guilty to that yeah
i do but also as as a host you're like i
got to move it forward what are you
doing next
the energy adventurer is what we're
doing next bill spindle sub stack
your cousin my cousin your cousin a
couple years older tell us about your
cousin so bill spindle he's been my
cousin my whole life
he's a couple years older than me
he
is an amazing journalist he was he's
been a journalist his whole adult life
he was editor of the daily at the
university of michigan and after that
has just pursued this career i think he
got his
um
his graduate degree in journalism at
columbia he worked for the wall street
journal for 20 years he was the former
south asia bureau chief for the wall
street journal covering india pakistan
nepal bhutan bangladesh sri lanka
also the former middle east bureau chief
he lived in abu dhabi for many years
he was in
new york city living downtown working
for the journal when 9 11 happened
and it's just been covering climate
change
energy
that you know that that sort of portion
of the world for a long time he's
currently
a council on foreign relations
international affairs fellow living in
india and he started this sub-stack
to kind of travel across india cover
climate change and in a broader context
the transformation of the global energy
system
and he's he's a wonderful writer and
he's sort of reporting boots on the
ground um and it's pretty cool what he's
done so in this world of subscriptions
and so many sub stacks i think he's
signal amidst the noise and everybody
should check it out so
the link is
billspindle.substack.com and i'll link
that up in the show notes yeah i read
great stuff on the indian railway system
which was really cool he it reads like a
journalism a journalist that's been set
free you know like like
doesn't have to right yeah he's not
reporting to anyone no but he's his
reporting is still good like that like
it's he's it's solid stuff but yet it
has a voice and it has a you know we try
to have a voice but usually it's kind of
restrained in in journalism but like his
set free and he's trying to he has a
point of view that's really interesting
and um
and i mean i think we always do but like
i said it's usually restrained this time
it's kind of set free and uh and i love
it and i've always said many times the
best
you know the best travelers are
journalists with their boots on the
ground in any country and they can teach
us so much so uh i'm gonna be staying
staying tuned in to bill that's cool i
can see you in another life with a sub
stack hoofing around the planet
is this my two weeks notice this is your
multiverse like if you were living in a
parallel universe no no i could you know
what i mean
no your job is security okay what would
you do without you um you know it's
funny i did that you know i did it for
nine months a year for lonely planet but
there was it was a pre-sub stack world
it was pretty sub stacking i don't think
at that time i would have made a lot of
made much of a living on substance i do
have an idea for a separate stack but i
got to get some stuff done this year and
then we'll we'll turn to it right on
yeah
all right well one of the main things i
wanted to talk about today
is this recent article that jonathan
height wrote for the atlantic which has
been up now for i don't know at least a
week and it's still the number one most
is it uh read story on the site
it's entitled
why the past 10 years of american life
have been uniquely stupid yes so you
want to launch into this for us yeah so
the background on the story is it's he
launches with the story of babel the
biblical story of the tower of people
who are
technologically advanced and they build
this massive tower but god curses them
to make sure they can't communicate
because it's it
and it becomes this metaphor
for social media and what we've done and
how that miscommunication has uh
imperiled groups and institutions and
the future of our country i think he he
talks about it as america but you know
this same problem is overseas many
places have these exact same problems
it's not just here brazil has had it
burma's had it many russia has it right
now
and so the idea is how do we get to this
point where people's idea of the truth
are so completely divergent and not just
people left and right but within the
right and within the left and what's
happening to
keep dialogue from happening and and
make us dumber and um and it it really
he really hands it hands it to mark
zuckerberg to be honest yeah for sure
and he talks about the kind of
inflection points along the timeline
where this really tipped into being a
real problem where we went from this
idea of social media being the great
uniter and
and this this uh modality that would
facilitate unity and communication into
kind of the dystopic division that we're
seeing uh and the increasing acrimony
between in groups i suppose is a way of
putting it um and i think what's you
know
first of all it takes like an hour to
read this article like it's not a small
thing like it requires you to really
kind of like wrestle with it and grapple
with it it's incredibly well done yeah
he walks you through kind of like how
social immediate social media evolved to
the point where these algorithms you
know are what they are that are you know
increasingly creating these information
silos but pre-share
what people like to retweet and and
share the most yeah um
but in addition to the
the the use of of babel you know as a
metaphor as an analogy it's also a way
of approaching this subject matter
through the lens of james madison and
the federalist paper yeah that was cool
as well as de tocqueville which i think
is fantastic right like i'm trying to
recollect my
study of these individuals as you know
uh as a young college student but
you know essentially like what madison
was saying which is true today is
um
you know you just can't quite trust the
masses right very emotional they're fast
which is kind of an anti-democratic idea
right but what people often forget is
that we don't live in a pure democracy
we live in a democratic republic there
are checks and balances on our
democratic purely democratic systems
that favor kind of institutional
stability and this was the whole idea
with madison's perspective in the
federalist papers and height makes the
case that
that idea that warning that madison was
you know forecasting
we're seeing in reality getting played
out in the democratic kind of forum of
ideas that social media avails itself
yeah yeah yeah um you know the idea that
madison is saying that humans kind of
tend towards factionalization and and
mutual animosity and so and he kind of
called this
and the zuckerberg point of it is kind
of like he paints zuckerberg as this
obviously no one's saying he's not a
very very smart guy so he's this genius
but he's a very very greedy very very
naive genius who kind of bumbled his way
um into something that it has cost that
he couldn't comprehend i mean he you
know like he was so taken with his
invention and the amount of power and
money he was going to make that he
didn't think of any negative costs and
so this idea of
lack of skepticism which started there
has then been passed i think he doesn't
actually say this but i think this the
fact that that the founders of these
platforms were so
lacked so much skepticism in what could
go wrong
or just
simply ignored it um that lack of
skepticism has been passed down to us
now and so now you have people because
one of my favorite parts of the story is
he basically breaks down
most of the people who are so political
on these platforms are a very small
minority of people they tend to be
wealthy white people and they're either
far right or far left right and when one
thing i notice when when people who are
super impassioned on social media
platforms like to make points almost
always they're not skeptical of their
own ideas right there's not a lot of
self-awareness around that hence the
dominant both sides yeah yeah yeah yeah
so he talks about this hidden tribe
study yeah um that was uh
that was implemented by this
pro-democracy group called more in
common that surveyed 8 000 americans in
2017 and 2018 and ultimately identified
seven groups
that shared beliefs and behaviors and
there's the one furthest to the right
that they call the devoted conservatives
which comprise six percent of the us
population and the one that's furthest
to the left that they call the
progressive activists comprise eight
percent of the population so we're
talking about 14 percent of the
population that really monopolizes
public discourse on social media because
they're the loudest and they're
the ones that get the most retweets and
shares which creates this
this you know uh uh imperfect
sense of what is actually transpiring in
households yes they're they're the bulk
of the the shares um
and and that they're and that they're
both like white and rich on the polls
right yeah
so we're being torn apart by a battle
between two subsets of the elite right
even though we're shouting about you
know the elites in the context of all of
that and what's funny it's like how i i
think last time we were on the air i
even mentioned this it's like i've i
said jokingly that you know if you're
being ultra political you're an [ __ ]
and so we're being torn apart by
[ __ ]
right so yeah basically that's the
that's the uh that's the tldr this whole
thing
right yes and
yeah yeah so
so in other words like
you know conservatives if you if you're
within you know an aspect of one of
those in groups on on on both sides if
you divert from that
let's say you divert from that
conservative perspective you're going to
get accused of being a traitor right and
if you yeah if you if you
um
uh take a position at odds with the
progressive side of it you're going to
get you're not going to get called a
trader you're going to get called a
racist a transphobic right or karen so
on one side it's the political
candidates if you're a rhino you lose
you have no chance but on the left it is
almost
more insidious because it can really
harm you in your daily life a lot more
and
i think he's a little bit breathless and
over dramatic about cancer culture i do
think it's a problem i think we've
talked about it we've talked about this
whole thing um
i i think it it it stems from academic
theories that have leaked into maine's
into our newspapers and but and even
kind of and i think it's a problem i do
think that there's basically the idea of
it in our daily papers
yeah sorry i was interrupting you again
no
um the idea being that
that that you know small percentage of
people who are screaming about that
thing finds its way into these
institutions into media and academia and
and even though it's such a small
percentage of people they're able to
hold those institutions hostage right
because the social ramifications
of of you know the shouting that's going
on about these issues it's the
consequences are too dire so
there's a retreat from really contending
with the issues and
and a kind of silencing of ideas that
results
as a as a matter of course right so you
think that's overblown no i i think the
way he frames it is a little overblown i
don't think um
you know i think he
one thing i think i have a quote here uh
the punishment that feels right for such
crimes is not execution it is public
shaming and social death i mean i don't
think every time something happens it
gets to that level but i think there are
examples of that sure there's plenty of
examples yeah yeah of uh professors
losing their jobs journalists getting
fired and like there's there's there's
quite a bit of it but it's it's more
about like okay so they may they maybe
there's not hundreds of those but
there's enough of them and what is the
chilling effect of that that's right no
100 you and i every almost every week we
talk about stuff we're not going to talk
about right well let's let's let's kind
of contextualize this article with the
conversation we had on the last roll-on
about leah thomas yeah so we tried to
have a balanced nuance conversation
about a very difficult issue
and and the challenge of of trying to
solve this problem of serving both
fairness and inclusion
and i think we did as best as we could
with uh with a problem that you know has
yet to have a solution and i can tell
you just publicly i was on the receiving
end of a lot of vitriol from both women
on the one hand
and trans advocates on the other hand so
women were angry that i didn't take a
hard a harder core position or you and i
didn't take a hardcore position on on
fairness and trans advocates were were
very angry that we were even having this
conversation without doing it in the
presence of a trans person right
basically making the argument that you
shouldn't even be talking about this
unless you have a trans person with you
so
which i completely i have a hard time
with that i i reject it completely well
if you're going to set up a condition
that you can't talk about this issue
unless you do a b and c
like most people are just going to say
well i'm just not going to have the
conversation right we have to be able to
talk about these things and yes would
that conversation have been more
informed had we had
um a trans person who's familiar with
this terrain with us probably
you could make the same argument if we
had a coach of a college uh you know
women's
team which is a women's song or whatever
yeah like of course any kind of like
experience based perspective on either
side of that would have better inform
the conversation but to say you have to
that's the problem right but the point
being that like publicly i felt like it
was hard like i'm not courting
controversy i tried to have that
conversation i felt like it was
important i think you and i agree on
that yeah
publicly it felt like i'd failed
everybody and you know had done like a
terrible job of even trying to do this
privately i got a lot of phone calls and
text messages and dms from people
thanking us for having that conversation
and those messages came from both sides
of the camp from women athletes women
trans people trans advocates
transparents and the like so
you know but that's one example of the
difference between
you know what is truly kind of like the
the
the larger quieter majority of people
versus the very loud polarities right
well we were speaking to that quiet
majority right which is what i think
people like about the roll-on stuff is
because we tend to do that i mean we
might get
onto the progressive side more often
than not but often we i don't think
we're that kind of religiously
progressive and so we talked we speak to
this majority and i think that's
important i think the majority needs to
speak up more and and support liberalism
and which is which is free thought and
free debate and free speech and it's not
in order to talk about this issue you
have to have this in your background or
you have to i mean that's crazy and it
doesn't i mean yes you should have
somewhat you should you should be a
serious person you should not you
shouldn't be talking about [ __ ] you
have no idea about it but like if you
study up you can have a discussion and
it doesn't matter uh your background so
i think that that's important i also
think that he he talked about um
the fact that uh you know
the left is the one that controls the
majority of written media entertainment
and all of this so there is this broader
impact of a quieter middle and a vocal
left and i you know i thought about this
when i watched because i had my
niece stayed with us and she wanted to
watch the grammys i don't typically
watch the grammys i've been like out of
the mainstream music scene for a long
time like i like what i like and i never
pay attention to grammys since i'm like
in high school and uh but i really
enjoyed it and the difference between
the oscars and the grammys
is like it's almost like
film and film people
seem to think that their job is
education
now
and the grammy people know it's
entertainment
and like your job is to entertain and so
like there's this there's this different
like people have a different perspective
that's why i have a problem with
academic theory in journalism it's like
yes you can be in the op-ed section but
academic theories should not impact news
reporting but everything is op-ed now
right there's so much yeah
but that's that's that's kind of my take
is that like people forget what their
primary job is it's a stay in your lane
idea we should focus on our primary job
if you're if you're
yes we need to have equal opportunity we
need to have more opportunity for more
people who've been shut out of the
system but that doesn't mean that your
job is in entertainment
that's that's how i look at it yeah back
to the substack issue though you're
seeing this flight of journalists from
these institutions that have been kind
of degraded in terms of public trust but
what's interesting is that
those sub stacks tend to be pretty
opinion for you know centrist like not
sent like opinion first right right that
it's it's it's
some version of of of activism
journalism for the most part in the most
popular substance that's true and people
who are distrustful of
the old guard the new york times
whatever
seem to have the inability to lend that
critical eye to the the opinion-driven
pieces of some of the big sub-stackers
well sure i mean especially if you look
at it on the left because who invented
opinion journalism rupert murdoch so
you're basically playing by that
playbook and it's a [ __ ] playbook
and because what these what what opinion
journalism does is what a lot of people
i've seen it before
people make they overstate their
argument and when you overstate a
winning argument or any argument but
specifically a winning argument you make
yourself look like an idiot
and it doesn't actually help the cause
and so
like
we should all be more restrained we
should all be trending more to the
middle we should all be thinking
actually you know what i don't know
enough i don't know [ __ ] really and
that's what you we were saying with the
leah thomas stuff was you know look
these are the these are this is what
it's at stake we didn't make any
judgments we just kind of presented all
of all the thought and feelings that
were out there yeah and did our best
well well put yeah well anyway but like
the the idea of
back to the austrians of grammys the
grammys was fun mm-hmm and the oscars
forming yeah the oscars didn't get fun
until the very end the oscars well that
got crazy yeah
um yeah it is a different vibe
like trevor noah's up there having a
great time everyone's having fun it's
like it felt like a global thing it felt
like free it felt like art it felt like
it's also much more diverse in terms of
the artists yeah you know from country
music to
hip-hop and and the like like you're
casting a much wider net in terms of
the kind of people that are adorning the
stage it felt like the silent majority's
preferred entertainment system to the
elite ivory tower weirdos okay there you
go yeah um all right speaking of elite
ivory tower weirdos we had a whole
category here of like cool stuff to
share and content that we're enjoying
but we're at like an hour and 30 in okay
so maybe let's just save that let's see
next time because we did the rollies
already so we had our yeah diversion
down entertainment alley uh that i think
is plenty for this episode and maybe
we'll revisit that next time so let's
just go to
we're going to go to this listener
question and then after that we're going
to go to a quick zoom call with chris
health let's do it
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes
into their daily routine sadly however
without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richrol.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering ten dollars
off an annual membership when you use
the promo code rr health at checkout
this is life-changing stuff people for
just a dollar seventy a week literally
the price of a cup of coffee again
that's
meals.richroll.com promo code rrhealth
for 10 off an annual membership all
right
let's get back to the show just as a
reminder we entertain listener questions
here if you want your question
considered for adam and i to talk about
on the show leave us a voicemail at
424-235-4626
that's
424-235-4626 do it now
our voicemail is standing by all right
here we go jake from
your old neck of the woods palo alto
here we go
hi rich and adam
my name is jake i'm calling from palo
alto california where i just relocated
five months ago i left my hometown
ventura california and dream job of four
years in order to be closer to my wife's
family
and in hopes for the betterment of our
marriage and future of our five-year-old
son i'm a vegan 37 year old primary care
doctor and swim bike or run for about an
hour every morning for my sanity last
month my larger-than-life younger
brother steve was tragically killed at
the age of 34 by a rogue power line that
hit him on the head
while he was working on a ranch six
months ago he married his high school
sweetheart after a 16-year courtship
that included world travels and great
adventures steve regularly swam in a
speedo in the san francisco bay even in
the winter
he surfed big waves snowboarders in the
backcountry went off of cliffs
and lived life to the fullest he was on
top of his game with ambitious goals
looking forward to starting a family
expanding his agricultural tech company
and was in the process of buying an
avocado ranch in carpinteria 16 years
ago my older brother dave died at the
age of 24 after heroic battle to
leukemia he was diagnosed with leukemia
at age six i was four and steve was just
one he was cured at 10 rediagnosed at 18
cured at 21. rediagnosed at 22 and had a
bone marrow transplant then suffered the
last year of his life on a ventilator at
cedar sinai hospital in los angeles not
once giving up the fight these
catastrophic losses have been
heartbreaking and trying to make sense
of them is emotional torture my
questions are
do you believe everything in life
happens for a reason and is there a
point in trying to make sense of this
incomprehensible life and world we live
in or does this just lead to despair i
respect you guys and appreciate all you
do the rrp has been an inspiration to me
that's heavy jake
it's a pretty heavy one
my heart goes out to you
this is heavy stuff real life stuff
um
and the questions that you're asking are
philosophical and and you know difficult
to
to answer so i'm not sure that i can
come up with anything that's going to be
fully satisfying to you but i i will say
this
to your question of
of whether we believe or whether i
believe everything happens for a reason
i mean i can't say that everything
happens for a reason in the universal
sense of the word 100 no yeah
and and of course you know i i i concede
and recognizing recognize the the
difficulty
and the pain
uh that you've experienced trying to
reckon with this and
in this
endeavor to kind of try to make sense of
something so seemingly senseless and
tragic and so
i think what i what i will say is that
that setting aside like is there a
universal point to any of this and focus
on
what i do know which is that i think you
can find solace in comfort in your own
personal attempt to find personal
meaning in these events because these
events
which are big heart events
present you with a choice on the one
hand you can either allow them to define
you in a self-destructive way
the world sucks nothing's good
bad things happen to me
but you know i probably don't have to
tell you that this mindset is not going
to serve you well
or on the other hand you can try to find
some spark in what has occurred to
ignite you in a more positive direction
when i look at or when i listen to you
talk about
your brother steve being this incredible
adventurer and how he lived life to the
fullest i can't help but think perhaps
that was a choice that he made in
response to your brother dave
and his early demise like looking at his
life and and realizing life short
and i've been gifted this life i'm going
to make the most out of it and
celebrating the fact that he lived his
life in that way and that was a risky
way to live and if you're going to live
your life on the edge do you know
surfing big waves and doing the things
that he did like
this [ __ ] happens you know and it
doesn't mean that the world is a
terrible place
i think he probably would say that he
understood that there was a risk in
living his life that way but that was a
choice that that he made for himself it
seems like the way it happened was such
a tragic accident yeah i mean it was
like freaking out that's not how yeah
like how he died so it's like i could
see how that would be like wait a second
and you
you do hear about that like these great
people who have this amazing lives and
then they die doing something random
like falling off the second story by
accident happens all the time yeah yeah
you know yeah but on that point of of
you know making this other choice like
this can come in many forms like you
could channel that energy to raise
awareness around leukemia or
or perhaps share transparently how
you're surviving this seemingly
senseless passing of a loved one
in other words like
can you take the unique experiences of
your life
tragic hard and flip them to fuel a path
in service to others and i think we see
this all the time like parents of kids
that are killed in school shootings
become activists or they start
non-profits to raise awareness around
these issues that have affected them so
deeply and personally
and i think
that you know heartbreak and despair
these emotions that you're experiencing
are
are totally you know they're totally
natural human responses to what has
occurred in your life and i think you
should feel all of that but
the challenge for you at some point
after you've felt all of it is to
um
process the events in a healthy way so
that they don't fester and become
you know the foundation for a lot of
unhealthy responses so you got to find a
way to make peace with yourself over
what happened
and transmute the events into something
positive for other people and i think
when you direct that energy outward in
service
that will provide you with a path
that's lined with meaning with purpose
with direction with fulfillment and it
doesn't mean you have to quit your job
or that this even needs to be your
primary focus but devoting some part of
your energy
or your intention
to that
first through
therapy or some kind of modality to help
you cope and
process what has happened to you which
is an act of self-love and then after
that
through service which is an act of love
for other people
that was so beautiful rich i i can't add
anything to that other than to say
you're a primary care physician as well
so you you've already lived you're
already living a very
cool life of like you're kind of leaning
towards service already
uh you know i think um
it's when you have a broken heart
you feel
i think you can feel more um what people
have gone through
i think it allows you to be more
empathetic
and i think that there's power in that
and uh not power like personal power but
power in in
in your ability to reach others and to
reach parts of yourself maybe that you
didn't even know were there and i just
want to commend you for living a cool
life already
and um
and for sharing this in this way and uh
you know life is a beautiful gift and so
we can't forget that no matter
everything that happens we have to
remember that life is a beautiful gift
whatever is happening out there
um it's it's it it's often tragic
um but but it is a gift so uh
we have to remember yeah
100 man 100
well good i think that's a good place to
put a pin in it we're gonna turn our
attention to
um a coaching call with chris but adam
thank you thank you appreciate you
appreciate you love you and i'll see you
back here in two weeks i love you too
where's my rollies let's go
we gotta we gotta design maybe we should
outsource the uh or just or uh uh you
know just put it out to the audience to
come up with designs for the rolly
trophy yeah
that's a good idea i i'm gonna go uh
celebrate with fellow rolly winner jason
camiola yeah at the after party where is
he after
yes behind the velvet rope yes yes right
of course very exclusive and elite if he
lost he might have slapped us
it would have been it would have been
rough i'm so glad that the audience came
through i'm glad too
um all right dude see you back here in
two weeks like i said i love you thank
you everybody for taking this journey
with me and uh roland we'll be back
in
two two weeks from now yeah yeah all
right peace out
but i guess the first thing i would ask
you is
you know what is the typical experience
with the athletes that you're working
with because i'm sure a lot of them if
not most of them have had covet at some
point so you have some
data points on
what's working what's not working people
who try to get back into it too quickly
etc
yeah yeah i mean that's the thing i
think it's gone through every one of my
athletes i can't really think of anybody
who hasn't besides myself that's the
crazy still haven't had it wow
not with four kids that's even more
surprising right um
so and we have to test also going to
different households because it affects
different households so if somebody's
feeling under the weather or something
like that so anyway but that being said
your question is a legitimate one
because it's across the board different
for every athlete but what i've found is
really two camps
one and this is the larger group it
takes longer than they thought
to kick out of it they have this general
sense of malaise
of just not being a hundred percent they
feel good enough to train they feel good
enough to do all the activities
but they're just missing a gear or two
and they're surprised how long it takes
and then
from one day to the next the cloud lifts
and they feel
mostly back to normal
and so in those cases yeah in those
cases are you just asking people to
train through it and deal with it or is
it better to just
take your foot off the gas completely or
slightly
well i think the first component there
is
you can train or i let them train how
they want to but recognize that they
might not be at 100 and not be so hard
on themselves because of it right we're
constantly evaluating how we're
progressing and so it becomes this like
oh i'm not progressing or i feel off or
i'm tired or i'm flat or i didn't eat
enough or something and i say you know
it might still just be this carrying on
for a longer period of time than you
think so allow yourself to
not necessarily once again train without
intention but give yourself that little
extra space of forgiveness quite
honestly
but you don't think that
the training itself is ill-advised or or
prolonging that recovery period
i haven't seen it
because those that i've given more time
off to or have backed off the training
completely
they're not necessarily getting
healthier quicker
interesting
and so
there's those who three four days later
are basically back to normal and then
maybe another two three days and then
they're 100
but then there's others three four weeks
of just feeling just enough to notice
that they're off that they just can't
perform let's say intervals or strength
work or paces that they were before
getting covered and so it's just a close
watching process for the athlete and
really providing the insight to me so
that i can say all right you know what
we're not we'll take out a few of these
higher quality higher intensity workouts
and just stay true to the endurance or
stay true to clean motions or just good
strength work maybe we're not looking to
top out the strength but just staying
connected to so that once you are
healthy
that you're ready to really hit that
gear and that's the fun right that you
as the athlete feel good about like okay
as soon as that fog lifts
at least i'm ready and i can have some
really good training days
well i feel pretty fortunate in that at
least so far i don't feel that malaise
or that general fatigue um
i i thought like i might have to take a
couple weeks off like i had athletes
pinging me friends of mine and i know
you know because i know them and their
friends i know that they you know
they're not afraid to train hard yeah
and a couple of them were like i took
three weeks off like i just needed that
but i felt
pretty good pretty quickly like after
four days i felt pretty much fine i was
like yeah but i'm gonna be conservative
i'm gonna sit this out and i think i
took seven days off total but
i felt ready to go and just
very gradually and gently got back into
the pool i didn't push anything like i i
would go three or four thousand yards
but i didn't really do anything very
hard just to gauge it and see how i felt
um but today you gave me a 4 700 yard
workout and there was some hard efforts
in there and i felt pretty good you know
and i got through it and that's the most
yardage that i've done and i know
there's a lot of volume waiting for me
but
i'm feeling pretty grateful that i'm not
in that camp of feeling like i'm missing
a step maybe that'll change but
right now that's kind of where i'm at
but i did miss seven days on a pretty
short
time window i'm now eight weeks out of
this swim
so there's a lot of work that has to
happen and obviously you know not
everything has gone perfectly to plan
and i've got a lot more
hiccups you know along the way over the
course of the next eight weeks including
this weekend where i'm going to be
driving up north
um to your neck of the woods for
an appointment for my back and i'm going
to miss a couple of swim days in there
as well because i'm doing it doing the
road trip with my kid and i don't want
to be just training all the time
yeah yeah well you know there's pools up
here too i could help you
that's true but like i don't know i'm
like hey hey jaya go sit in the corner
while i go train like i gotta balance
that you know it's supposed to be kind
of like a
father-son road trip
yeah yeah so with that being said it's
hard to know where you're at with
regards to the health because you might
have felt pretty good today because you
also had a weak lighter leading up to it
to really absorb the training that you
were doing prior and also increasing
sort of the build as you were going so
it's hard to know that until we're a
couple
days further down the road here at which
point you're taking a couple days off so
that's why we're taking the windows and
you're you're just a classic example of
most any athlete that has a full-time
child as a family right like it's
stressful for all of us and that's the
whole challenge how to navigate these
little windows of when we can train and
using the time we have to maximize the
fitness gains and so
here we are eight weeks out to do 21 000
yards in one
fell swoop
right so what am i looking at here how
how you know how how how is this volume
going to escalate because i'm itching
i'm always itching at this phase to be
doing more and you're always like
pushing me to slow down a little bit but
i've worked with you long enough to know
like those days are coming
yeah well the beauty is we're starting
that sort of the bigger prep this week
um with some longer sets i'm hopeful
that we can get in two key workouts this
week and they include some long
continuous swimming
and you're gonna curse me plenty then um
when you say i want to do more and then
i have two 1800s straight for you
waiting with four minutes rest
and you're gonna do that in the pool and
be like really this my brain is going
mush back to our youth no i love that
stuff but the good thing is is that with
that you know with our watches these
days we no longer have to count remember
back in the day if we had to swim longer
we didn't know if we missed a 50 or 100
or something now we can just look at our
watch so lucky on that
but that being said it's a great
opportunity to swim 3 600 yards broken
and to do some fueling and hydrating
halfway through to see how you're doing
with that
and just
we want to get better at finding that
all-day swim day pace right swim pace
excuse me so that rhythm and that pacing
that you can just turn the brain off and
just keep swimming and getting familiar
with that so that now we have a baseline
for going along in order to do that just
a bit faster and using that in our
training in order to work around it you
know um a few seconds faster than all
base one base a few seconds slower than
albay swim paste so we can start setting
the intervals and the work around that
right
um a couple questions the first thing is
i got some good open water swims when i
was in miami and i have a lifetime of
open water experience so i've never been
uptight about making sure that i'm in
the ocean doing
um doing workouts because i'm
comfortable enough to know that like
when i get there it will be fine but
do you think that it would be wise to
start incorporating some long course
workouts in because i'm swimming in a
25-yard pool and i specifically go to
this pool where they overheat it because
it's more of like an older person
therapy pool
uh but that's perfect for the
the environment that i'm gonna do this
women it's gonna be really hot
so i want to acclimate to the heat and
the overheating
but i do think i would be well served by
getting some long course workouts in but
i have to drive great distances like
either to pasadena or way out to simi
valley to get access to a 50 meter pool
yeah so that will take some planning and
again if we have to um choose between
getting to a 50 meter pool or getting in
a longer workout in a 25 meter pool
because you're using your training time
to drive i'd rather right right because
you're going to and i say that we're
both nodding our heads because i'm
saying that because you already know
okay that what the benefits are a 50
meter and you know how you'll feel
getting into the open water and and
lengthening out your stroke and just
finding that all-day pace so is if that
means we spend 45 more minutes in the
pool versus driving and you get in
another 4 000
that's sort of the equation that we need
to play in these last eight weeks given
that you have limited
time every day anyway
right i think that that those moments i
could pick those moments though where i
do have more free time like on a weekend
or whatever and you know you and i both
know that no matter how fit you are
short course when you get into a long
course pool and you throw down pretty
hard like you're gonna be sore the next
day like it is different in a meaningful
way
and depressing too yeah cause you could
you thought you were
you were fake and next thing you know
you're like out of breath on a couple
hundreds long course don't lie
yeah no that's a whole different and
it's a different swim sport i mean just
knowing from being swimmers we know both
know people who were world class
at short course meters or even yards
ncaa swimmers and then you put them in a
50 meter pool they never even qualified
for
you know the olympics let alone up to
their potential than the world fastest
times they were doing in the ncaa swims
so it's it's it's almost a different
swim sport so
right
so when you're looking at how much work
i've done and how much work remains to
be done are we talking
survival here like where where where you
know like like obviously i'm not going
to be tip top
uh but i would like to be more fit than
just trying to get through it
for sure
with also knowing like i'm not going to
be able to hammer the way that i would
prefer if i lived a different life
well there's always that risk we could
just throw the
throw the dice out there and see what
happens yeah
you know it's salt water you'll float
long enough um no but you had to look at
it this way that you woke up today
after a week sort of off and and gently
building your fitness back in and
quickly in three four days or trying to
and you did a quarter of the distance
basically this morning
so
if we needed to push ourselves could you
have done a third or even up to half
today and back off the pace
substantially but just continue to keep
going probably you'd be sore tomorrow or
a little bit more fatigue but
you could so we're that's where we're
moving to next where you do half the
distance and you feel like you did today
for a quarter of the distance
that's our next check-in point now
hopefully that happens in the next two
three weeks so we have five weeks to go
to sort of add that last little
component are we going to do the full
distance of course not are we going to
do three quarters of the distance most
likely not because we missed that window
but will we go 12 13 000 yards and you
feel good about that yes
yeah that seems totally doable and if i
can throw down 12 13 000
and not be completely wrecked that's
the enough confidence for me exactly
that and fueling and hydrating during or
the combination in swimming because you
sort of
fuel with hydration right that um
that will sustain you in hour three and
so forth so that you feel good versus
getting fatigued and you think it's
fitness where it's actually running low
on fuel
those com that combined with as you're
building the volume i think you will
have plenty of confidence going into 21
000 yards yeah the hydration and fueling
piece is the next thing because i
haven't done any experimentation with
that i just go with water or nothing so
far because the workouts haven't been
long enough to justify it
but starting to play around with that
is something i'm eager to begin doing
especially in the higher temperature
water where perfect yeah it's more
meaningful
and what have you so what have you
obviously this is a very personal thing
but
what have you determined in your
experience and you know all the open
water marathon stuff that you've done
that seems to be a good workable
equation
yeah so for me it's first off in the
warmer temperatures it's hydration right
electrolyte hydration is that at least
that component i'm staying topped off
with regards to hydration because we
dehydrate in warm water dramatically
yeah and it's hard to recognize until
it's too late
until we're completely sort of
dehydrated and it's affecting our
performance the second part is that you
will have that opportunity this weekend
just before i forget that to do to 1800s
with four minutes rest and so you can
start laying out some different products
whether that's gels or chews personally
i like to choose
if i'm going to eat something solid i
can get through them pretty quickly wash
it down with water and keep swimming
anything more substantial like a bar or
anything like that i'm still
chewing hard and working in that rest or
even swimming one-handed backstroke
while we're continuing to swim and
that's not ideal so therefore we have
the chews gels or bottles with calories
in them and there's plenty of those but
products out there that are really good
that have really advanced the technology
over the last few years
there's a variety of products out there
like precision fuel and hydration
there is martins so there are these
bottles that have 200 300 calories in
them a lot of electrolytes plenty of
sodium and therefore you can also
get your calories in for what we're
looking to do we're not going that big
in a deficit for your 21 000 is probably
gonna be around five six hours and so
that's not going to be something too
dramatic that with a good breakfast
being topped off and staying on top of
it with
liquid fuel you'll be pretty
well versed in that by then
right on
with the added complexity of salt water
exactly and so that's why you want
cold fresh water so that you can rinse
out your mouth so you can get rid of
that
that
that hunger debilitating sensation in
your mouth that's salty water you don't
want to eat anything or drink anything
you're just like right you know so
therefore we want to be able to test
that over the next few weeks
cool
yeah all right so we'll check back in in
two weeks where would you like to see me
then
versus now
well that's where we're going to start
adding those longer swims so in two
weeks you're going to have might be even
up to 6 000 7 000 where you feel pretty
comfortable and you feel like you know
what that wasn't so bad like i got out
went out and went on with the rest of my
day then we're starting to get good that
we can quickly extend to
10 000 or 11 000 because the beauty of
six to seven to eight thousand let's
just say 65 to 8 000
10 000 11 000 is no difference it's just
more time in the water but your arms and
your body doesn't feel any different and
you're going to laugh because it's
really remarkable how you feel just as
fatigued at 7 200
as you do at 9 800. you're just like i
spend more time in the water but i'm not
necessarily more tired and that's our
next sort of
you know threshold to cross
all right
sounds good man i appreciate all the
sage counsel of course i'm actually
really enjoying this it's nice to just
kind of do one thing i can't tell you
the last time i just swam like pretty
much every day and didn't have to worry
about all the other stuff because
even during the most intense kind of
ultraman training
we were still only swimming like two or
three days a week at most right so you
never got that day in day out
um
cycle of swim training that compounds
much more quickly when
versus when you're wedging it into you
know the swi the cycling and the running
isn't the the psyche sort of so happy to
be returning to this ritual
isn't it bizarre it's like going back
into the womb yes
i i kept telling emily last year or two
years ago last year when i was getting
ready for the length of tahoe i was like
i miss this this just being able to swim
forever or turn on the gears
automatically or just settling into a
really smooth swim pace the day in day
out it just comes so naturally and it
feels so good for us we're used to
staring at a black line at the bottom of
a pool
and it is crazy for anybody who's
watching or listening
because we have so
so robust the background like even at 55
like i know that i'm still tapping into
what i started to build when i was 12 14
years old yeah and it's just going back
in the mind going oh yeah i remember
this feeling that i can just click two
hundreds and three hundreds over and
over again and i just
there it is it's fine
right
cool man well always appreciate it we're
glad to see you're healthy
yeah you're healthy and you're starting
to look like a swimmer again
i know my hair has gotten fried you know
it's like i wear i wore a cap when i had
long hair but i was like my hair short
i'm not wearing a cap and now like my
hair is completely fritzed out from the
chlorine
but i'm kind of like yeah that's what
you do when you're a swimmer
it's just that we didn't have beards
back then when we were i know
yeah let alone completely white beards
well it's good to see you're healthy and
i'm glad you're back and i will um dive
into your training
as we speak sounds good thanks my friend
i'll talk to you soon all right
[Music]
so
[Music]
you